how is life now these days which is
pretty awesome
yeah i'm pretty broke it drives me crazy
that you're broke and i'll tell you why
drive you crazy yeah
how do you think it's good for me
because you are
a true student of boxing you knew you
know
you're one of those guys who really
understands boxing where boxers come
from yes
and so when you look back at boxers
traditionally they've gotten hosed every
step of the way they generate tremendous
amount of income
forget about what goes on gambling wise
what they generate and all that
but it seems like every boxer ends up in
the hole always ends up getting beaten
down
financially well there's a really small
percentage that don't probably a half
percentage that doesn't
right but this is um listen when i was a
young kid i heard about
um joe lewis and sugar ray robson you
hear about all these great fighters
tony cam and mary lou and you hear about
these guys um
amazing fortunes and lost it and you
know this stuff you all know this stuff
but they still they knew about the guys
before them in the 10
right in the early century and the 20s
but still
we go broken why because handling money
is an
art it's more than handling money and we
never practiced that art before
does it keep you up at night now like
knowing how much money you you probably
had personally about 400 million dollars
does it keep you up at night now where
you go
[ __ ] never never never i never never
once in my life i said [ __ ]
i just um i had everything i ever wanted
and i have everything i wanted now
and plus when i had all that money i was
so living such a chaotic life
i wasn't really enjoying myself it was
better if i was even dead at that time
i remember how shocked i was when buster
douglas fight happened this is like the
more shocked than i was busting landing
these all night
by boston look at this he's not fighting
down for the first time in his career
i always figured you just didn't want to
win that fight like like you'd had
enough because
a you were out of shape for the fight
yeah and it was almost like you're like
okay let me [ __ ] lose this thing
already and be done with it it was
almost like committing suicide
kind of in a way yes because that's why
when i um when i retired that was
another form of suicide
but it's killing some bad stuff not
killing a good person you're killing the
right person
but we don't know how to get the person
that we're not supposed to kill
out of the body of the guy that we
should kill yeah i understand that
i know you wouldn't understand that one
it's like you almost don't know you know
the money's coming in
you're mike tyson you're this huge
success but meanwhile you're miserable
you're [ __ ] miserable i'm the most
miserable person that i've ever met in
my life with myself
right when i was at that height of
fighting and successfully right right
so all of a sudden how do you end all of
that in a way
but you keep the good guy alive right
you know um
it's all an inside job man it takes so
long
it takes a long time a therapy a long
time of just um challenging your
decision-making qualities you're going
to make a lot of mistakes
doing this stuff but um you have to get
it done and it's going to kill you
does a vande of holyfield is he a
wealthy guy did he hold on to his money
no he was getting foreclosure statements
are you friendly with him at all now
very friendly yeah you are yeah does he
look at you every time so why the [ __ ]
did you bite my ear off
no he never does do you have an answer
for him
what is the answer i'm sorry i'm [ __ ]
i'm sorry but that's so not you you are
a fan of boxing and you are
you were an aficionado of boxing but i
wasn't a boxer back then i was just a
guy doing living my life
were you scared that night no i'm never
well i'm scared every night but never
scared that
someone's gonna beat me up kind of
scared right what is that feeling like
when you [ __ ] take your fist
and you [ __ ] pound someone until the
point that they pass out
it's like drugs right it's like drugs it
gives you everything you want
yes but it takes back so much more in
return
what does it take back everything your
soul yeah your spirit just so how do you
think about how do you
i wanted to take people's nose and stick
it in their brain
how do you want to do that if you're
humanitarian how do you want to do that
to another human being because you want
to kill them right but that's back then
yeah right
back then and so the point is that you
really are a sensitive guy inside and
that sensitive guy was almost like you
couldn't let him out or else you
wouldn't want to put somebody's nose
into their brain
i guess no i don't want to hurt any
anybody no more like that hey did you
ever meet muhammad ali
yeah was he the greatest of all time um
there's no doubt but not only this
i've met mohammad ali probably a hundred
times every time you meet him it's like
the first time you know there's
something special about this
gentleman right here where do you see
him where do you where do you meet with
him
first time i met him i was in spa for
juvenile detention i was in
uh and he came to visit the kids like i
do i come and visit kids at hospital
that's crazy
yeah was that like a defining moment in
your life i knew that's what i wanted to
do i wanted to be
i didn't know if i wanted to be a boxer
but i knew i wanted to be famous
right and you were what about 13 years
old
probably 11. and you're in the center
and like
look who shows up it had to be a great
day i mean you probably didn't have many
great days there
we had a great day there there was a
bunch of kids there the kids the bunch
of kids they were fighting everything
they were stabbing each other
playing basketball that's great yeah it
sounds like hell to me
i think you're kidding yourself that
that was great not to have a family not
to have
um listen um if you never had it how
would you know if it was great or bad
everybody's mother and father was my
mother and father do you ever meet joe
frazier
did i many times i fought his son member
right what a great [ __ ] guy
marvin did you love did you love joe i
love him so much but what i love more
about jordan anything than
fighting that one day i'm in england i'm
doing my meeting and greets but i'm
watching a joel frazier they had
tapes because he did a meet and greet
and i'm watching the tape you know it's
just me in the room
yeah and i'm watching the tape and i'm
watching how humble he is
when i saw him how humbly was i i want
to be like you know even though
i said wow you know such a ferocious
fighter just takes his head off and he
was so humble
i always say to joe man you're the real
champion because you know
man what muhammad ali did to him i still
take umbrage with this
when he would call joe a gorilla and
call him names
i didn't think that was right joe was a
great champion he didn't have to go
there i agree with you but this is
something you have to know
um all that stuff is the art of war too
i know it's all in the game right that's
more enticing than the actual fight
actually
thought what he thinks about this guy
personally like when you would fight
holyfield did you have to go in there
and hate him oh that's how you make
great fights
yeah and that's why the fight game maybe
isn't so great now these guys don't have
this [ __ ]
anger that that anger they want to get
their money and not get hurt you have to
get ready for money but even so i used
to try
fighting the unwritten rule not now but
when you um sign that contract it's
always a possibility
that you can die during the training and
during the fight it's unwritten but you
know that you've seen it happen
right the people you know and people you
didn't know so you know those are the
possibilities and guys today
just want to get out and get their money
and get the hell home but it's like a
business
yeah there's no free there's no free
meal here you have to bleed for that
food